[Music]
now back to Katy Perry as we know she's
the first one signed on to the new
American Idol yes indeed and they
reportedly broke the bank to get her so
this morning when I talked to former
Idol judge Paula Abdul well I just had
to get her take on it she said it
herself
I'm getting paid I'm really proud that
as a woman I got hey yeah good for her
while Katy celebrates a reported 25
million dollar contracts
the numbers are bittersweet for the 54
year old singer really paying you enough
let's just put it on the record yeah I
was not getting 25 million dollars
currently on her total package two of
halle left idle after eight season
reportedly over money but she hasn't
ruled out a return did you go back if
they came to you I don't I don't think I
want to do the judging thing anymore
but if they ever called me and they
needed help or mentoring what the kids
are doing anything like that that's what
I do that's who I am it's a great show I
think it's still the best of this kind
ever last night ET caught up with ab
duels former fellow judge Randy Jackson
who gave His blessing to the new Idol
and joked about being approached they
wanted me to take Ryan Seacrest to jail
because they said look man look you got
it you know how to do it dog yo dog and
while Idol doesn't hit the ABC airwaves
until next spring the competition with
NBC's The Voice is already heating up
Jennifer Hudson and Kelly Clarkson made
their careers on Idol but producer Mark
Burnett has already tapped them as
coaches for his show known Kelly for a
long time she was a visor
Jennifer's amazing those pipes so we're
just got two brand-new coaches can't
wait to see the fireworks between Blake
and Kelly got the book but fire alright
VM perhaps in real life but that's the
best food
[Music]